[Música]
la energía no es fácil de definir las
cosas tienen energía pero no puedes
tomar un manojo de energía en tus manos
puedes ver lo que hace pero directamente
existen diferentes tipos de energía pero
las diferencias se manifiestan sólo en
cómo hacen que las cosas se comporten
para los químicos dos tipos importantes
son la energía potencial química y la
energía cinética la energía potencial es
la que está en espera de ocurrir piensa
en una cinta elástica estirada si las
cortas toda esa energía potencial se
convierte en energía cinética que las
registras por el dolor que sientes
al igual que la cinta estirada los
enlaces químicos también almacenan
energía y cuando se rompen esa energía
potencial se convierte en otros tipos de
energía como calor o luz la energía
cinética es energía de movimiento y las
moléculas siempre se mueven no van a
algún lugar necesariamente aunque
podrían pero están vibrando estirándose
doblándose o girando por ejemplo el
metano tiene cuatro hidrógenos enlazados
a un carbono central
él es sólo un tetraedro estático pero en
la vida real no para de moverse la
energía cinética de las moléculas es el
mismo tipo de energía que la energía que
tienes cuando te mueves excepto que
mientras tú puedas estar inmóvil las
moléculas no si le sacas la energía
cinética a un grupo de moléculas se
moverían menos pero nunca se detendrían
completamente es un grupo de moléculas
algunas tienen más energía cinética que
otras si calculamos la energía cinética
promedio del grupo tendríamos un número
matemáticamente relacionado con la
temperatura mientras más energía
cinética tenga un grupo de moléculas
mayor será su temperatura eso significa
que en un día caluroso las moléculas en
el aire que te rodean están girando
estirándose y doblando se más rápido que
en un día frío en un día caluroso de
verano las moléculas de aire tienen más
energía cinética que las moléculas de tu
piel cuando esas moléculas de aire
chocan contra ti transfieren algo de su
energía a las moléculas de tu piel y
sientes eso como calor
es un día frío las moléculas del aire
tienen menos energía cinética que las de
tu piel cuando chocan contra ti
en realidad transfieren algo de tu
energía cinética a ellos y sientes eso
como frío inténtalo en tu próxima
parrillada quemas carbón y la liberación
de esa energía potencial química se
manifiesta en calor y luz extremos el
calor hace que las moléculas de tus
hamburguesas perros calientes y verduras
vibren hasta que sus enlaces se rompen y
nuevas estructuras químicas se forman
demasiado calor y quemarás todo justo lo
suficiente resulta en la cena una vez en
tu cuerpo las moléculas de la comida se
rompen y la energía liberada se usa bien
para mantenerte vivo o se almacena para
después en moléculas diferentes cuando
cae la noche el aire caliente del verano
se enfría y disminuye el flujo de
energía hacia ti y luego empieza otra
vez en la dirección contraria conforme
la energía abandona la superficie más
caliente de tu piel para regresar al
universo a tu alrededor
energía ni se crea ni se destruye sino
que cambia de forma eternamente el fénix
camaleónico de nuestro mundo físico
[Música]